i've been telling you for months
if there's a real problem with the
women's march
and that the problem is outrageous
extreme views including anti-semitism
including anti-lgbt uh individuals
being spoken of favorably by
the ranks of the leaders of the women's
march
hateful rhetoric racist rhetoric
anti-semitic rhetoric
that is quite frankly not that different
from what many of the participants in
the women's marches claim to be fighting
against and i have really good news for
you today
teresa shook is a co-founder of the
women's march
she's calling for the problematic
leaders of the women's march to step
down
and i support her one hundred and ten
percent let me remind you before we get
to teresa shook's
statement one co-chair tamika mallory
is a big fan of notorious anti-semite
and by the way a guy who also seems to
like trump louis farrakhan of the nation
of islam disgusting vile guy
tamika mallory leader of the women's
march has called him the greatest of all
time
linda sarsour another co-chair also a
fan of louis farrakhan
her anti-israel activism crosses the
line
way beyond just being an advocate for
palestinian rights
into straight up anti-israeli and
potentially anti-semitic
activism now i'm not calling her an
anti-semite
what i'm telling you is that her
rhetoric and actions
are anti-semitic and are cow towing to
anti-semitic
beliefs and conspiracies she has praised
the muslim brotherhood which is a
radical group
she has praised sharia law which
literally mandates
women be second-class citizens and is
completely
anti-lgbt that's not very women's marche
that's not very progressive she said
months ago that american muslims
shouldn't
humanize israelis i i they are human
right
if anyone on the left said the same
thing about
muslims shouldn't be humanized she'd be
outraged and so would i
by the way sarsour has promoted
the anti-semitic conspiracy that jews
can't be loyal
because of their quote allegiance to
israel that's a standard she would find
outrageous if someone said
imagine for example muslim immigrants
from
qatar can't be loyal here because they
have an allegiance
to the rich qataris who are funding
terrorist
group hamas she would be outraged
rightly so
and yet she says something similar about
a different group
these are really some of the worst
people to be leading a supposed leftist
civil rights and human rights group and
now i am pleased to tell you
that the women's march co-founder teresa
shook is calling for them to step down
she posted to her facebook page a few
days ago bob bland tamika mallory linda
sarsour
and carmen perez of women's march
incorporated
have steered the movement away from its
true course i have waited hoping they
would right the ship
but they have not in opposition to our
unity principles they have allowed
anti-semitism
anti-lbgtqia sentiment
and hateful racist rhetoric to become a
part of the platform by their refusal
to separate themselves from groups that
espouse these racist hateful beliefs
i call for the current co-chairs to step
down and to let others
lead who can restore faith in the
movement and its original intent
i stand in solidarity with all the
sister march organizations to bring the
movement
back to its authentic purpose as women's
march founder i am stepping up to bring
focus back to the unity principles on
which our movement began
and with the support of all those who
marched and have continued to march
i pledge to support grassroots
decentralized leadership
promoting a safe worldwide community
devoid of hate speech
bigotry and racism i couldn't say it
better myself
hate speech bigotry and racism have
pervaded
the leadership of the women's march and
teresa shook
is getting some praise for this but
she's also being slammed
by people who are unwilling to see
the problems that exist within the
leadership of the women's march
this is no group that i want anything to
do with
for as long as people like this are
involved i'm not
anti-semitic i'm not anti-lgbt
i'm not anti-woman so how can i in good
conscience how can i in good
faith how can i look at the facts
and say i approve of the leadership
of the women's march i can think of no
more anti-progressive action than that
and uh it's it's teresa shook is getting
crushed by a lot of people
she's getting attacked for this post
she's saying things that i've been
saying for months if not
closer to years at this point and i
think it's absolutely great
this is a mo uh this is a movement that
at least claims to want the right things
which is good
but it's allowed ties to hate speakers
and racists
and homophobic movements and systems of
law
to become in some way accepted and i
hope that more people will do what
teresa shook is doing and demand
that these individuals be uh uh pushed
to step down and relinquish involvement
with the women's march and
and and when they do i will be the first
one out there saying
now this is a movement that i can get
behind
one of today's sponsors is privacy.com
pacman this is a free service that i've
actually been using myself for a while
now and i love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card
or bank account to privacy.com mobile
app or browser extension for firefox and
chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not
actually putting your real debit card
number
on the internet and you use these
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online and with one click of a
button
you have the ability to create multiple
virtual cards delete cards freeze and
unfreeze cards you can put a limit on a
card
so a company won't be able to charge you
more than you actually want them to
and it protects you from being hacked it
protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program
and it's perfect for signing up for free
trial somewhere if you don't want your
real credit card number
to be exposed and on file and their app
and browser extension
let you autofill the virtual credit card
number into the credit card field
when you're buying things online there
are a ton of different
advantages to shopping and paying bills
with a system like this everything is
totally secure
and encrypted and in some situations you
can earn
five percent cash back on your purchases
it's all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets five dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below